we go to our coverage of the coronavirus
as the supply of the coronavirus vaccine
increases vaccination sites here in the
valley are expanding their hours
getting the medicine is getting a little
bit easier at all the big sites hector
mahia live this morning with details on
these new hours hector good morning
good morning john the las vegas
convention center here right behind me
is one of the three large locations that
now have extended hours and this is
going to help those people who
are usually busy during the middle of
the day possibly with a nine to five
work schedule
so we have the new schedules for you
starting today appointments here at the
las vegas convention center are open
until
5 30 pm for those who are eligible it's
pushed out to 6 pm
at cashman center in downtown and over
at the southern nevada health district
main site they start in 30 minutes at
7am
health officials are trying to clear up
some misconceptions about the vaccine
that are still floating out there
number one you will not have to pay an
out-of-pocket cost to get the vaccine
even if you are asked for your insurance
card number two
people will not be turned away if they
do not have a nevada id
an id is required though so the dose can
be reported
during yesterday's covet 19 mitigation
task force phone call
officials went over some of the big
challenges
they've been facing the volume
the magnitude of really trying to offer
a vaccination to every single adult in
the state i think
has never been done before as we know i
think that
is definitely the most difficult aspect
we've worked really hard on you know
communication
across the state nearly 18 percent of
all nevadans have gone at least
one dose of the covet vaccine at this
point the state has
not announced plans to expand eligible
groups currently it's still for those
65 and older plus those in front line
health care and community support roles
do you have any questions and you want
to talk to a human being we all have a
lot of questions about the vaccine
there is a 24 7 call center that number
to call is 2-1-1
i called earlier this morning and
someone answered the phone right away
reporting live this morning hector mejia
8 news now